[موسيقى]
يستعدوا حلف شمال الاطلسيه لاجراء مناورات
عسكريه في المانيا وصفت بالتدريبات الجويه
الاضخم منذ تاسيس الحلف وتتزامن هذه
المناورات التي ترمي لاظهار القدره على
الانتشار السريع والفاعل مع اخرى تحت
تسميه
تستمر في رومانيا يشارك فيها عشرات الاف
الجنود من 25 دوله على وقع تحديات
المتعاضمه مع روسيا والصين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه مسارات ثلاثه ما اهداف هذه
المناورات وما السياقات الاقليميه
والدوليه التي تجري فيها السيما الحرب في
اوكرانيا وما ضلالاته مكانها وزمانها ايضا
كيف نقرا العلاقات الامريكيه الاوروبيه في
هذه المرحله وما هي حدود الاتفاق
والاختلاف بين الجانبين وبين الاوروبيين
انفسهم بشان ضم دول جديده من شرق اوروبا
الى حلف الاطلسي او الى الاتحاد
الاوروبيين وما هو مستقبل دول الشرق
اوروبا في ظل الصراع المحموم بين الغرب
وروسيا على مساحات النفوذ في هذه الدول
واي خارطه للتحالفات المتوقعه في تلك
المنطقه في المرحله المقبله
[موسيقى]
لا يريد حلف شمال الاطلسيه يضيع منه اي
وقت وهو يجابه وتحديات المتصاعده يجيء
اغلبها واهمها من الشرق حيث تستمر الحرب
في اوكرانيا ويستمر التوتر مع الصين بين
المانيا ورومانيا تتوزع تدريباته تريد
تدريبات تريد الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى
اعضاء وحليفه ان تظهر القدره على التحرك
بسرعه ونجاعه قريبا من بؤر التوتر
والمواجهات مسؤول عسكري امريكي قال
للجزيره ان المناورات تتضمن التدريبات
جويه عابره للاطلسي تعتبر الاكبر من نوعها
واضاف القائد العسكري الامريكي واضعا
للمناورات في سياقها الاوسع اضاف ان
المشهد الاستراتيجي العالمي تغير تماما
بعد حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ويشار لان هذه
الحرب تخللت ايضا نقاشا امريكيا اوروبيا
واوروبيا اوروبيا بشان انسب الاستراتيجيات
الامنيه والسياسيه لمجابهه التحديات على
المستويين العالمي والقاري
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني واستاذة
والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث بالمركز العربي
في واشنطن ومعنا من باريس الدكتور زياد
ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه في باريس وابدا بك دكتور خليل
العناني هذه المناورات تتضمن تدريبات هي
الاضخم من نوع منذ تاسيس النيتو ما السياق
الذي يمكن ان نضع فيه هذه المناورات بهذه
الصيغه
انا اعتقد هناك السياقات عديده جدا الساق
الاول طبعا كما هو واضح تماما هو الحرب
الروسيه الطحينه حاليا في اوكرانيا خاصه
في ظل هذا الضربات المتواصله وربما لاول
مره نشهد بعض الهجمات من اوكرانيا على
روسيا خاصه فيما يتعلق باستخدام طائرات
مسيره والتي تم استهداف الكريم باحداها
واستهداف ايضا محطات نفطيه في روسيا
وبالتالي هناك حاله تصاعد الحرب هناك ما
يتحدث عنه البعض وهو متعلق او العمليه
الهجوميه
الاوكرانيه على روسيا وبالتالي هذا سياق
مهم جدا وهذه مناورات تاتي في اطار ارسال
رساله مهمه جدا روسيا فيما يتعلق بان هناك
حاله اتحاد او وحده داخل النيتو بتكلم على
اكبر مناورات منذ انشاء الحلف قبل 74 عام
وحتى الان على الاقل 250 طائره طبعا هي
منارات جويه بالاساس وليست منورات بريه او
بحريه بالاساس جويه عبر الاطلسي ايضا امر
غير مسبوق على الاطلاق 250 طائره على
الاقل 24,000 جندي من امريكا ومن دول
اوروبا بعض الدول المحاذيه
لروسيا موجوده في هذه المناورات خاصه دول
البلطيق الثلاثه وبالتالي او الرساله هي
رساله موجهه الى روسيا بان هناك حاله
اتحاد ان لم تكن سياسيا على الاقل عسكريه
فيما يتعلق بالوضع في اوروبا خاصه في شرق
اوروبا باعتباره جدارا عازلا ما بين
اوروبا الغربيه وامريكا وبين روسيا الامر
الثاني متعلق بما نشهده على مدار اخر
اسابيع فيما يتعلق بالتوتر المتصاعد
ومتزايد بين الصين وبين امريكا خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالبحر الصين الجنوبي هناك حاله
توتر واضحه جدا للغايه
رساله موجهه ايضا يعتقد انهم حليفين
رئيسيين هي الصين وروسيا خاصه في ظل الحرب
الحاليه هناك حاله حاله من التعاون شبه
الاسترليني بين الطرفين الروسي والصين
وبالتالي هذه المناورات تاتي في اطار
ارسال رساله مهمه جدا لاكبر قوتين
عسكريتين في العالم هما موسكو وبكين فيما
يتعلق بان هناك حاله استعداد قصه في الحلف
الاطلسي خاصه
يتعلق بامكانيه تفعيل الماده خمسه من
ميثاق النيتو فيما يتعلق بان اي هجوم على
اي دوله ولو صغيره داخل النيتو يعتبر هجوم
على كل الاعضاء وبالتالي هناك حاله
استعداد تام لهذه المساله
الكثيره وهنالك ايضا اختيارات
تم اختيارها لارسال هذه الرسائل من ضمن
هذه الاختيارات مثلا التدريبات التي ستجرى
في او تجرى في رومانيا في البحر الاسود من
ضمن هذه الاختيارات كذلك
اكبر تدريبات جويه اكبر انشاء اكبر قوه
جويه يقول قائد عسكري امريكي انه قادر على
الانتشار في اي مكان كلمه دكتور زياد ماجد
كلمه الانتشار في اي مكان الوصول لاي مكان
في العالم
ووفق هذه الاختيارات التي جرت فيها
المناورات والمكان
ما المقصود بها ما المقصود باي مكان في
العالم
يعني بدايه حلف شمالي الاطلسي بحسب قانونه
داخلي هو حلف دفاعي بهذا المعنى
المناورات هذه جديده برسائلها لانها تقول
ان قدرته على الانتشار الجغرافي واسعه جدا
ان مفهوم الدفاع بات ايضا موضعه بحث لان
الدفاع يمكن ان يكون
بمعنى ما استباقي او يمكن ان يستخدم في
حاله تعرضت اي
بلد باي دوله او مدينه من مدن حلف شمال
الاطلسي لعدوان
والرساله بهذا المعنى ترتبط بالخريطه
الاوروبيه بشكل اساسي وهذا ربما اختلاف
يعني نوعي بين اوروبا وامريكا اذا كانت
امريكا ترسل رسائل الى الصين وليس فقط الى
روسيا ففي الحاله الاوروبيه التركيز هو
على الموضوع الروسي وليست مصادفه ان تكون
بريطانيا هي رسميا التي تنسق هذه
المناورات بالتعاون مع جمهوريه تشيكيا كما
ان دول البلطيق تشارك فيها بشكل اساسي
والرقعه التي تفضلت الى الاشاره اليها وهي
على مقربه جغرافيه مباشره او تماس جغرافي
مع روسيا من خلال البحر الاسود رومانيا
هذا يدل ايضا على ان الاوروبيين يبعثون
برسائل وهم زادوا في الاشهر الاخيره
موازنتهم العسكريه التي كانت دون الاثنين
في المئه التي يطالب بها حلف شمال الاطلسي
صارت في بعض الحالات 4% كما هي في حاله
بولونيا من الناتج القومي طبعا او الناتج
الوطني الاقتصادي
والعقليه الاوروبيه يمكن ان نقول ان
التراجع الكبير في الموازنات العسكريه بعد
انهيار جدار برلين ونهايه الحرب البارده
يتغير بشكل جذري الان مع ارتفاع الانفاق
العسكري واوروبا تريد ان تقول انها عادت
لتصبح شريكه في النيتو في حلف شمال
الاطلسي وتصريح مكروه بهذا المعنى ان
روسيا اعادت احياء او ايقظت حلف شمال
الاطلسي من نومه العميق تشير الى القرار
باظهار عضلات عسكريه جويه ولكن ايضا قدره
انتشار جغرافي واسع يمكن ان تكون مباشره
على تماس مع روسيا وليس فقط يعني على
مسافه ما او على شكل رادع بل ضمن انخراط
مباشر في عمليات اذا تطلب الامر
تحدثت عن
حلف الاطلسي وهدفه الاساسي وهو هدف دفاعي
ونحن نتحدث عن رسائل بالصين نريد ان نعرف
انعكاس ذلك ايضا على العلاقات الاوروبيه
الامريكيه بعد قليل لكن الجنرال مايكل
هو هو
قال في تصريح للجزيره ان الاولويه اولويه
هذه تدريبات المشتركه في المانيا هي الرضع
وجهزيه القوات اذا
الجنرالو وهو قائد الحرس الوطني او حرس
الجوي الوطني الامريكي ادنى بتصريحات بهذا
بشان اهداف هذه المناورات بشكل مباشر
هذه اكبر حركه تدريب جويه عابره للاطلسي
ننفذها تضم اكثر من 50 وحده معا للوصول
الى قوه جويه متماسكه من سلاح الجو
الامريكي ليتم ادماجها جميعا مع اربع
وعشرين شريكا دوليا المانيا هي التي تقود
العمليه ولدينا خارج المانيا شركاء دوليون
يشاركوننا للتاكد من انه يمكننا جميعا ان
نكون جاهزين للتشغيل المتبادل بشكل كامل
من اجل الحصول على الاستعداد ثم الردع
الجماعي
الردع هو عنوان حلف الشمال الاطلسي الرضع
هو هدف دفاعي دكتور خليل العناني
الاوروبيون لهم وجهه نظر على سبيل المثال
فيما يجري بين الولايات المتحده والصين
الرئيس الفرنسي قال بشكل واضح لا علاقه
لنا بما يجري في مضيق تايوان هل مناورات
المانيا ومناورات رومانيه بهذه الصيغه
بهذه الشكل بهذه اللغه تعني انه تم تجاوز
هذا هذه النقطه نقطه الخلاف هذه
بشكل او باخر رجب ان نعيد النظر فيما
يتعلق بمسرح عمليات النيتو هناك ثلاث بؤر
رئيسيه تحرك فيها الناتو من خلال هذه
المظله الدفاعيه بنتكلم على اكبر حلف
دفاعي في العالم حاليا 30 دوله على الاقل
وبعد انضمام في قد يصل الامر الى 32 دوله
فبنتكلم عن اكبر حلف دفاعي في التاريخ قد
يكون ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه وثلاث مناطق مسارح
للعمليات هي اولا روسيا وشرق اوروبا قد
يعتبر هم كبير جدا فيما يتعلق باوروبا
تحديدا خاصه اوروبا الغربيه والمخاوف
المتزايده من اي هجوم او اي تهور روسي
فيما يتعلق
باقامه حرب او دخول فيها حرب المسرح
الثاني متعلق في مطلق او المحيط الهادئ
وهذا يرتبط بالاساس بالصين الصين متواجده
هناك بشكل او اخر هناك تواجد عسكري كثير
جدا في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي النيتو كمظله
دفاعيه تشمل كده الامرين تشمل اوروبا تشمل
ايضا منطقه المحيط الهادئ او الباسيفيك
الامر الثاني المتعلق الاوسط لكن اول
منطقتين هما المسرحين الرئيسيين لتحرك اي
تحرك للنيتو فيما يتعلق بالرد على الدفاع
وبالتم صعب جدا ان يتم اخفاء ان هناك
بالفعل تركيز امريكي حتى وان كان هناك كما
قد فضل دكتور مجد وقال هناك روسيا لكن
ايضا المخطط الصينيه بالنسبه لامريكا
بالنسبه لاوروبا ايضا متزايده وهناك ايضا
حديث تم نشرها او تم اذاعتها قبل فتره
فيما يتعلق بامكانيه اعطاء اليابان صفه
عضو من خارج النيت وهذا يعتبر تحول خطير
جدا لو حصل يعتبر كانه استفزاز للصين كما
حدث الامر فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا عندما تم
الحديث حول امكانيه اعطاء اوكرانيا صفه
عضويه داخل النت وبالتالي لا يمكن الاطلاق
عن النص بين الامرين بين وجود مناورات
جويها الاكبر في تاريخه وبين المخاطر
العالميه التي يعتبر جديده جدا فيما يتعلق
بالنظام العالمي حاليا هناك اعاده تموضع
للقوات الدوليه خاصه بعد الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا وكما قال الجنرال العسكري
هناك وضع عالمي جديد يتطلب وجود جهزيه
كامله لحلف الناتو متعل تهديدات الان
الصعود الصيني ليس فقط الصعود الاقتصاديه
وتكنولوجيا صعودا عسكريا في الصين في
المنطقه بحر الصين الجنوب وبالتالي جزء
رئيسي من التزمات حلف الناتو اتجاه اعضائه
فيما يتعلق بمواجهه اي تهديدات صينيه
لامريكا في تلك المنطقه من العالم
وهل هل يقرا الاوروبيون ذلك ايضا الدكتور
زياد ماجد ان هنالك تهديدات صينيه مباشره
لامريكا
على حدود امريكا يعني الواقع يقول امريكا
هي التي تنشئ قواعد عسكريه على حدود الصين
وليس العكس
نعم يعني كان واضحا في هذا الصدد الموقف
الفرنسي الرافض لفتح مكتب تنسيق في
اليابان لحلف شمال الاطلسي من اجل الابقاء
على خفض التوتر او لا اريد القول النائب
النفس لكن اعتبار اوروبا انها غير معنيه
مباشره بتصاعد التوتر الصيني الامريكي بلا
شك ان الاوروبيين يعتبرون الصين تحديا
اقتصاديا
ويعرفون ايضا ان الصين باتت باستثماراتها
وعلاقاتها على مقربه من حوض البحر المتوسط
بسبب حضورها الاساسي في الشرق الاوسط في
بعض الدول الافريقيه
ويعيرون المساله الصينيه اهميه لكن ليس من
منطلق عسكري هذا المنطلق يخص الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اكثر والتميزات
الاوروبيه الامريكيه حتى الان ما زالت
قائمه على هذا الصعيد لكن يدافع عن اعضائه
في الولايات المتحده
والولايات المتحده في هذا الحلف الولايات
المتحده تتعرض بحريتها مثلا كما تقول في
في جزيره غوام القريبه من الصين البعيد عن
الولايات المتحده لكن تظل الجزيره
الامريكيه في نهايه المطاف تتعرض للتحرشات
الصينيه هل يعتبرها حلف الاطلسي تهديدا
لاحد اعضائه
لا لا اعتقد ان هذا يعني موضوع اشكالي
فيما يخص بتعريف معنى تهديد دوله او عضو
من دول حلف شمال الاطلسي لاسيما فيما
يتعلق بشق الترابي او الجغرافي البلد نفس
البلد ثم هناك
الارتيك الخمسه او الماده الخامسه التي
يمكن
ويتطلب اجماعا اعتبارها قائمه لكي ياخذ
حلف شمال الاطلسي اجراءات عسكريه ضمن
الدفاع عن دوله تتعرض سيادتها او تتعرض
اراضيها للخطر اما ان كان هناك يعني
اشتباكات او توترات في مناطق بعيده عن
الاراضي
السياده الوطنيه يصبح الموضوع قابلا
للكثير من الاخذ والرد والدليل على ذلك
مجموعه عمليات عسكريه قد ينخرط بها اعضاء
في دول شمال الاطلسي خارج نطاقهم الجغرافي
ولا يعتبر الموضوع دفاعيا مباشره
حتى ولو كانت مظله العمليات ضد الارهاب او
العمليات الاستباقيه هي المستخدمه لكنها
لا تفرض على الحلف ان يكون يعني بهيئاته
المشتركه منخرطا في العمليات فقط في موضوع
اوكرانيا
المساله باتت مرتبطه كثيرا الان بدول
البلطيق وقد سبق المناورات الجويه الحاليه
مناورات عسكريه بريه ايضا في بعض الغابات
في دول البلطيق التي هي على تماس جغرافي
مباشر مع روسيا وهذا كان رساله اوروبيه
بالتحديد لان المناورات كانت بطابع اوروبي
اكثر من الانخراط الامريكي فيها كان اشاره
الى ان هذا الحيز الجغرافي الاوروبي هو
الاولويه الاوروبيه المطلقه
والجيوش الاوروبيه شاركت في هذه العمليات
بوصفها عمليات دفاع بريه عن دوله قد تتعرض
لعدوان دكتور خليل العناني ماذا عن مقترح
انشاء قوه اوروبيه هل هل ما يجري من
مناورات اليوم تجاوز هذه المرحله مرحله
حديث الفرنسيين عن قوه اوروبيه كي لا تكون
الاوروبا رهينه
بالقرار العسكري الامريكي
انا اعتقد من الصعب جدا وجود اي قوه
اوروبيه بدون وجود يعني تحالف او تعاون مع
امريكا امريكا في النهايه تمثل مظله امنيه
مهمه جدا لاي تحرك او اي قبه قوه اوروبيه
وبالتالي صعب جدا الحديث او توقع وجود قوه
اوروبيه خالصه بدون وجود اي دعم عسكري
امريكي سواء دعم عسكري مباشره او غير
مباشر نحن ازاء كما قلت قبل قليل اكبر
تحالف دفاعي في التاريخ هناك حاله شراكه
استراتيجيه من هذه الدول وبين امريكا
تعتبر من اهم الدول التي تمد النيتو
بالسلاح وبالقوات وحتى اكبر ميزانيه داخل
نيته هي ميزانيه تاتي من امريكا وكان هناك
انتقادات كبيره جدا وجهها رئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب لدول النيتو بعدم القيام
بدورها فيما يتعلق بالتمويل ودعم حلف
وبالتالي من ارى انه قد يكون من غير
الواقعي وجود اي قوه اوروبيه مشتركه بدون
وجود تنسيق على الاقل مع جانب الامريكي في
النهايه امريكا دوله عظمى على الاقل تمثل
كذلك بنسبه الدول الاوروبيه هي ورثه
الامبرا الامبراطوريه والبريطانيه بشكل او
باخر لديها نفوس انحاء العالم بغض النظر
بقى عمال اتفقنا او اختلفنا معاه في
النهايه هي قوه عالميه لديها مظله نوويه
مهمه جدا وبالتالي مقترحات بوجود قوه
اوروبيه يعني فقط داخل اوروبا قد تكون غير
عمليه من ناحيه الواقعيه هناك حاجه
اوروبيه ماسه لوجود امريكا فيما يتعلق باي
تحرك عسكري سواء كان عسكري ضد روسيا او ضد
اي مناطق اخرى في العالم وبالتالي قد يكون
تحالف او قد يكون مقترح غير عملي قد يكون
الهدف منه هدف سياسي بالاساس من اجل فك
الارتباط مع امريكا وهناك طبعا باختلافات
موجوده بين الطرفين بلا شك فيما يتعلق
سواء بنطاق عمليات حلف النيتو سواء فيما
يتعلق بتوسيع حدود النيتو باتجاه روسيا
سقما يتعلق بضم دول جديده في النهايه يظل
التحالف الاستراتيجي بين امريكا وبين
اوروبا مهم جدا فيما يتعلق باي تحرك عسكري
او استراتيجي يفتك المنطقه من العالم هذا
التحالف الى اي مدى يمكن ان يمتد دكتور
زياد ماجد شاهدنا كل المشتريات الموجوده
الان بسبب اعتراض روسيا على امتداده شرقا
وم حاوله ضم اوكرانيا مسيره الامتداد شرقا
هذه ما المدى الذي يمكن ان تصل اليه
يعني الان هناك مشكله بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
ولحلف شمال الاطلسي في قوانين حلف شمال
الاطلسي لا يستطيع ان يضم دوله او دول هي
في حاله حرب وهذا يعني ان اوكرانيا لن
تنضم في القريب العاجل انما هناك من خلال
مفاوضات مع اوروبا ومن خلال اعتبار ان ما
يجري هو تهديد لاوروبا اعتبار ان اوكرانيا
هي شريك او هي حليف او ان حلف شمال
الاطلسي معني بامن القاره الاوروبيه
والبوابه الاوكرانيه بهذا المعنى تصبح
استراتيجيه لكن طبعا دول مثل لاتفيا او
استونيا او ليتوانيا تعتبر نفسها مهدده
دوله مثل بولونيا لديها حدود مع روسيا
مباشره في الجيب الروسي داخل اوروبا ايضا
تعتبر انها مهدده
ورومانيا مولدافيا هناك اعاده بحث في هذه
الجغرافيا شرق اوروبا التي كانت جزءا اما
من الاتحاد السوفياتي او المعسكر
الاشتراكي وهي بالمناسبه الاكثر حده في
مواقفها من روسيا بسبب تجارب الماضي وبسبب
الخوف من الابتلاع ان لم تكن جزءا من
منظومه حلف شمال الاطلسي او من اوروبا لكن
التوسيع الان برايي مفرمل ولو انه بعد ضم
فنلندا هناك مباحثات حول السويد ونعرف
الموقف التركي حتى الان من ذلك لكن غير
السويد المساله قد تكون مرتبطه اكثر
بابقاء العضويه على ما هي عليه بانتظار
نهايه لهذه الحرب التي قد تطول لفتره
اضافيه ومن بعدها جغرافيا حلف شمال
الاطلسي برايس يعاد النظر بها ودول اوروبا
الشرقيه التي زادت من موازنتها ستصبح اكثر
ديناميتا واكثر ارتباطا بالحلف وبالتحالف
مع واشنطن واوافق تماما الضيف دكتور عناني
ان واشنطن هي القوه العظمى الاساسيه التي
تريد اوروبا تمايجا عنها لكنها لا تستطيع
ان تكون في تمايز كامل معها اذا تحدثنا عن
مواجهه مع روسيا او مع تنافس سيشتد مع
الصين اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من باريس الدكتور
زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه الامريكيه في باريس ونشكر ضيفنا
من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والباحث بالمركز العربي في واشنطن
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر في امان الله
[موسيقى]